so my name is Jose Esparza I'm a junior
in mathematics and economics in Econ
my focus is development economics so I
got to know Michele's
professor degraaf's work because of what
he does with the MIT Haiti initiative
and the reason I took this course is
because I thought that his efforts were
very important and that it was just like
an opportunity to improve the world and
I wanted to learn more of what he did
and like the theory of why he does what
he does after taking this course my
perspectives of language and identity
changed in that now I was able to see
the connection between the languages we
speak but also how that ties into
cultures in general but and more
importantly to politics in some sense we
can see a lot of the big things that
happen in society like neo colonialism
or the cloud or the effects of
institutions a lot of these things
although they might be cloudy and some
sort they become like language is a good
way to view the world world one of the
first essays was to look our our own
life or a biography through the lens of
language and in some sense studying is
how institutions interact with each
other through this lens of language
opens up either how some cultures are
not taking as seriously as others how it
tells you about the history that about
the world and subsistence it taught me
to see language is something that ties a
lot of the things about humans together
and it was just like a different way to
look at the world